Marcus Silva says check out Oscar
nominee Sam Elliot back in his Gary days
tell you how quickly I would have been
staying at Scot Thompson's house oh my
god I wanted to take my mom anywhere
yeah I wouldn't even know and shooter
pick me up at school she would pick me
up from Hartwood Athletic Club where I
went to after school and should've been
like here's a backpack you got underwear
your toothbrush you're saying it's not
for the week he's the ultimate guy
that's gonna bang your mom my mom is I'm
not lying to you going with me and
Christine to see cher in Philadelphia
mm-hmm because we had the conversation
about seeing the musical and I said they
didn't even mention the movie masks and
my mom goes oh masks that's the best Sam
Elliott mmm do you think your mom would
I told her you do it yeah she lit on the
phone yeah it's Terry Sam it's good
disappointed by both my parents on the
phone today is like such a devout
Catholic woman doesn't even utter a
curse but if you put a picture of Tom
Selleck up I know absolutely Trish would
run through me like a wet paper towel to
get the Tom Selleck I could be I could
be I could be dying of like food
poisoning or like choking Tom Selleck
was like well you come out to my car and
yeah throw me a Hedra Beej my long as I
can well Tom Selleck stays warm my mom
just flicked her beam to bluebloods and
you get an older mature Don Wahlberg
yeah Tom Selleck on Blue Bloods
is the Cinemax for moms
yeah past menopause absolutely like when
women go past menopause they watch Blue
Bloods yeah way young teenage boys used
to watch Cinemax absolutely oh god I
hope there's some stability yeah I hope
if Tom Selleck does like a really evil
man oh my god I imagine my mom just yes
sitting down and like her cloud pyjamas
with my with our dachshund Larry just
getting hot flashes watching having to
get up for a refill of a martini yeah in
between the commercial breaks moving
Riley and Oreo guys move I need to get a
refill with the middle finger she does
dig her eyes off the screen she's goes
still looks good after all these years
oh that's - it really does Tom King fell
CROs right into a mom Bush if I was a
punk band I would name an album your mom
wants the Tom Selleck yeah oh for
sure showing up at any guy any of our
mom's house are you doing my car broke
down Tom Selleck do you mind if I use
the phone she's like my mom has been
vocal about not wanting to have sex with
Samuel Jackson really Wow yeah Wow that
dude is ashy I bet for years she's
always like Samuel Jackson oh man I
wonder how many moms throw it at Samuel
oh oh you know who's another one you
know is another one that moms wanna
my mom wants to absolutely bang
out Kurt Russell tango and cash go
backwards yeah she wants to her
Russell
big trouble with China there's no as no
one ate for for coming I know what's
called in the state who's they think was
their mom great rod Brooks our
buddy that you met in San Francisco he
did is radio show you did wrong oh yeah
yeah he texted me and he said my mom's
would have thrown me in a river to
Teddy Pendergrass yeah that's the black
she won't have had to that's the black
Selleck his life ended in a wheelchair
so she could have got him by the yeah
she could has ran him down or just stood
in front of me she threw you in the
river for that rod she just wanted to
throw you in the river she goes but I
get an excuse I want everyone's parents
to turn on the Teddy Pendergrass yeah
but it wasn't about you even as looks it
was the voice oh yeah that was one
soulful yeah juh mom my mom's not I
thought that was him hey what's up
can they make me a plate to bring home
after I bust off in your mom mom you've
been working all hard at know your son's
playing video games turn the tv up or
you're gonna hit your mom getting
hard let's do it in the shower so that
you can't hear I'm wondering who else is
on the list
Bichette Pendergrass Russell Michelle
Excel that's number one
yeah sucks number one my mom has been
vocal about in my aunt Eileen they want
Dave always want to have a threesome
with Michael Bolton Michael Bolton he's
another big one but but again Selleck is
one I'll tell you one that went for my
mom 70s 80s 90s and now Kenny Loggins
mm-hmm
buddy I saw a billboard for Kenny
Loggins
let me say right now right now no church
can wash it off he did it
I'm telling you he he went café's he is
the cat face that's sad
look at Kenny Loggins now there's me and
there's the picture actually
oh come on Ken it's odd-looking why he
looks like a trans man you know what he
would say if he was talking like this
but I'm all right
don't about it worry about me Kenny the
surgery went through we grafted you
perfectly with a Siamese cat Dean from
Maryland says uh sure Dean held your mom
that's a young mom that's a young mom my
mom would have tore those jeans off like
PA guards lucky yeah my mom wanted to
Garth Brooks
so guys jeans like weirdly like on his
belly full of Garth you're talking to uh
you're talking about a Colorado mom
Garth Brooks would get hit in the face
with a pair of yellow cotton panties
dude I'll tell you this Trisha Trisha
would have flung some legs at
James Taylor yeah she absolutely my mom
would definitely have had a pedicure for
Garth Brooks
I mean Garth Brooks would have just he
could have came in and ate all the
cupboards bare and my mom and
left and she
really love GB Brooks yeah
and James Taylor my mom is big James
Taylor guy soulful 80 years now Garth
Brooks is be a big Kenny Loggins host my
mom wanted I remember her being like
Jenny Atlanta says Michael Keaton but
that's that it's not for like anything
with like the look I don't I don't know
that's timely Jason Texas Woody
Harrelson okay I would like my mom more
if she wanted to Woody 90s Val
Kilmer tombstone oh yeah two more doors
Val killed my mom was into Val Kilmer
yeah not Mia not where's a
t-shirt and a wading pool vacuum now not
that he's been dead for a week now kill
me you lying down says this is an
interesting one to me mark mcgwire eli
your your mom particularly mark seems
like a very specific yeah but 98 he's a
big ginger yeah he's a big ginge
my mom's into gingers I can't answer the
baseball players it may have been
specifically a my mom always would be
open about one how hot and how long tall
O'Neal's legs Oh guys up for Evan legs
for days stems on that pictures I'll
tell you this I bury my face in between
those yams yeah like your dad's stubby
legs father's lying legs
what are you there he's not there yeah
Mark McGwire's inch that's a fetish
almost uh redheaded bossed around by a
Viking yeah by a Scottish like
goody mad Missouri says a mother would
drown him in a tub for a shot with the
doctor himself Don Johnson Don will you
forget you Don Johnson was getting mom's
wet hot handsome is your mama's
morning she's like I'm a Tubbs lady oh
yeah
like Philip Michael Thomas yeah like mom
you got a swing for the fence
that's a kid that's the kid that grew up
sleeping on a couch in the living room
she's like Edward James Olmos that would
have been Crafton if she's a little bit
older I mean if we're talking about your
mom how'd you late in life and she's in
her 70s yeah Burt Reynolds
oh my god my mom is in here my mom 70
and I think Burt Reynolds you gotta
remember a deliverance Burt Reynolds
when he was in shape oh man Gator
although a lot of people like not so
much in shape but like you know casual
freewheeling Smokey and the Bandit
burger that's a fun Burt knows MUNs mom
is really uh giving themselves a
front wedge over like the captain or not
- Kevin what was he Jack in Boogie
Nights I think you Selleck it's just if
you're a white woman here I would do if
this is family feud yeah and the
question was baby boomer white women
wanna Tom Selleck the answers time
so it's been a long time since and we
figured that we were talking about the
Punisher that's all those characters
they shave their chests for the show but
Tom Selleck one of those big things that
big furry chest yeah I think Burt
Reynolds also that's not a thing looked
upon if that was I mean there'd be
staples in the middle of a bunch
of Joe DeRosa pictures he centerfolds
all day Rosa's got a Bon Jovi
chest young banjo look at that
Stephanie Falcone said after bringing
her to a few shows at her request and
seeing her in that situation I'm pretty
sure my mom would be down for Big Joe
I'll give her the biz nice man I got her
stoned
Stephanie Falcone is a hot name yeah
Coney she's letting her mom bang J /
yeah pretty good remember when you bang
Stephanie fell Sean Connery good job
Ryan you change it India that's not what
Sean Connery I can hear my mom getting
wet watching blasters as you got older
dude that's what I'm saying well yeah
truce we'll just undo it
[Laughter]
in the kitchen she maybe he made Tom
Selleck dude it's like it's Highlander
situation between Connery and celery
yeah I can't believe we forgot about
Sean Connery Oh Sean Connery six with
your mom Oh welcome to my dude look
at him I mean stone-cold Fox
he's no life too right Sean Connery he's
like retired from acting yeah so good /
absolutely Brian Dennehy he's like
you're you're my steps are now dog oh
yeah Nicole G good call Springsteen yeah
and that's the music there's a musician
oh that's all that's affecting a
musician yeah another musician do you
mind if I eat all your cuckoo crisps
another music what's up last night
Trish there's guys running low
on milk now I just thought of a song and
dance still sleeping they're out of milk
should I wake them up or dizzy the rest
of the cereal Springsteen he throws like
a you need to insulate these walls
and break yo cross at scary movies I
don't walk on the Sun but he insists oh
I'm not saying he's gay I've never seen
a boy cry so much hates the sight of
blood he sucks on a bike I'd give him
back if I could he names his stuffed
animal homes and he keeps the people
that's really weird
it scared is like believes in sin I he's
11 years old
[Music]
mom's banging in no particular order
Neil Diamond check not my mom pass only
my mom might have given the Six Million
Dollar Man for sure I don't know about
yours I can't answer for Ted Danson yes
yes and let me answer some of them
I'm insulted that I didn't know for my
mom mr. Pierce Brosnan yes
Pierce Brosnan chrous if I said I'm not
that that's a big one for the TEG
Rob Paul Newman of course Robert Redford
Robert Redford those are the stand-in
Costner yeah Warren Beatty those ones
are - oh that's what I was saying more
like the the singers of the yeah time
because Robert Redford and Paul Newman
both of them by the time I would look at
them to be like oh this is what the
girls are all excited about it was like
yeah they were I kind of grizzled you
know Robert Redford aged like bizarre
when he started the age when it when it
went so you went like like he wilted
like a ginger man Paul Newman he's just
like a drawing on salad dressing
at this point yeah I forget everything
he did did your mom ever get remarried
no no but she had like two long-term
boyfriends did you like him I liked the
one I didn't like the one Y island my
friend's dad he was long-term he what
they dated for like five years and then
he started dating a woman who lived
directly across the street so he dumped
my mom I was like 17 when they got
dumped this is in Brooklyn this is in
Brooklyn literally directly across the
street like I'm talking about like the
house across street he started dating
that woman in there and it like broke my
mother's heart yeah yeah my mom did you
talk to your friend about it yeah I mean
it was like everybody was just a dick
anyway like we nobody's really friends
there's always a dick so was his dad so
my dad one time came to pick me up take
me to a basketball tournament and my mom
was sitting in a chair looking out the
window like weeping you know like um he
was like what's wrong with your mother
and I was like you know the he broke gym
broke up with her and he's like what do
you do anything about it and I was like
what like I'm a kid and he was and he
was like I was playing video games and
he was like I'm gonna go get bagels and
then he rang the
Bell across and then all of a sudden I
hear my mother yelling Kristen stop Tony
what are you doing and my dad had him
like up against like the steps and was
like shaking him cuz my debt and then my
dad came back and was like a whole thing
the police were called but like nothing
happened and my dad came back and he was
like you can't have your mother crying
like that he should have taken care of
that yourself yeah and I was just like I
get and then we went to Staten Island
and he draw and he was like look I'm
sorry shouldn't have done that and he's
like you know he there's always the same
same store with my dad he would do
something he wasn't supposed to do and
then but it's really just cuz he loved
me and then he would explain to me on
the ride how I should not do like what
he taught what I what he just did
shook shook him he pushed him around a
little bit he like scared him and he was
like look you know you can't date this
lady anymore and then I I don't I never
saw the guy again when none of us ever
saw him again I mean he's okay but I
think he stopped dating that woman
that's crazy and my mom what a weird way
to break over the woman you go a man
threatened me yeah was that yeah I got
threatened by a man yeah my ex's ex told
me that if I keep dating you he's gonna
cut my off I'm afraid so
I like my dick yeah so that's crazy yeah
that's what happened oh man yeah and
then I was telling you my dad apparently
like this was before I was born or maybe
my mom was pregnant with me dan Aykroyd
was in central they were laying in the
park and laying on the grass in Central
Park my mom and my dad and Dan Aykroyd
apparently allegedly came by and
rollerblades or a skateboard and like my
dad was like went to go take a piss
behind a tree or something like that
he had stopped and was like hitting on
my mom Wow yeah my dad on roller skate
yeah the rubber stopper down yeah my mom
my mom said like my dad was like close
to getting in Ackroyd's face how
Oscar that be if I get my dad punched in
and beat the out of my dad yes I
mean if a Ghostbuster takes out your dad
while wearing roller skates oh there it
goes talking Detroit
[Music]
you